le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
faire garder son enfant est une
préoccupation majeure des parents à la
réunion pour faire face au manque de
places et aux frais de garde
dans un contexte économique déjà
difficile le département veut
accompagner les parcours de vie de ces
familles depuis 2012
il propose aux plus modestes le chèque
marmaille une aide financière sur les
frais de garde
martine et marie anne ont toutes deux
besoin de mettre leur enfant en
structure d'accueil elles bénéficient de
ce dispositif
aux premières heures du matin à saint
denis martin et sa fille prennent la
direction de la crèche un endroit que
schaden connais très bien depuis l'âge
de trois mois
la petite fille est en structure
d'accueil sa mère n'a pas eu d'autre
choix là aujourd'hui elle a à deux ans
et demi j'ai personne pour garder mon
enfant
son papa travaille jusqu'à 18 heures
donc j'ai pris cette option là je puisse
travailler sereinement tout en sachant
qu'à l'égard de martine travail est le
même dans le milieu de la petite enfance
le manque de places en structures
d'accueil est une problématique qu'elle
connaît bien et par emprunt s'y prennent
tôt avant la naissance de l'enfant
après on a énormément de demandes qu'on
dit malheureusement on peut pas
satisfaire tout le monde parce que voilà
de plus en plus on a beaucoup de blessés
pour faciliter des démarches déjà
compliqué martin bénéficier du chèque
marmaille un coup de pouce financier sur
ses frais de garde
c'est un carnet trimestriel d'un montant
de 210 euros
donc tous les mois on déduit 70 euros
sur la fin car ça soulage un peu le
porte-monnaie si je puis 10 à 50
salariés différence une facture c'est
une grande aide je trouve ce dispositif
est mis en place par le département pour
aider les familles les plus modestes à
accéder au mode de garde
selon leur quotient familial permet aux
parents d'obtenir une aide financière de
70 à 250 euros pour les parents trouvent
déplacent plus facilement
et puis deuxième objectif nous avons
aussi beaucoup bd les métiers de la
petite enfance à se structurer à créer
de l'emploi chez des assistantes
maternelles ou bien à tous ceux qui
avaient un ca paix ou 1/2 p et je crois
que le troisième objectif sociétal il
est celui de permettre à une femme de
pouvoir reprendre une activité parce que
faire garder ses enfants
parfois ça permet de reprendre son
boulot
reprendre son travail ou en chercher un
marianne est au chômage depuis cinq ans
elle vient juste de mettre son fils en
crèche pour se consacrer à la recherche
d'un emploi faut d'abord commencer par
ça pour être disponible pour parce que
là si on m'appelle demain qu'on était un
poste qu'il correspond quoi vous je
suppose et donc il faut vraiment mettre
j'essaie de mettre toutes les chances de
mon côté pour cela la mère de famille a
fait appel elle aussi aux chèques
marmaille
elle a reçu son carnet en moins de trois
semaines ses 2 200 euros répartis sur un
trimestre c'est vraiment un soulagement
parce que ça coûte très cher de l'un de
ses enfants mais en plus on peut même
quand même si on ne prend pas de place
dans une structure on peut le petit
emmanuel vient donc de commencer son
intégration dans sa structure d'accueil
besoin d'avoir des amis elle a besoin de
plus d'activités des trucs lorient plus
pendant que son fils épanouie dans son
nouveau milieu
mariën peut chercher un emploi l'esprit
tranquille
le chèque marmaille par l'aide aux
familles les plus modestes de bénéficier
d'une aide pour le paiement de leurs
frais de garde
il s'adresse aux familles dont le revenu
mensuel est inférieur à 2000 euros
elles ont alors droit à une aide maximum
de 70 euros par mois en structure
d'accueil agréée 100 euros par mois si
l'enfant est accueilli par une
assistante maternelle
si l'enfant est porteur de handicap les
familles peuvent bénéficier de 250 euros
par mois sans condition de ressources
le chéquier est envoyé par la poste tous
les trimestres les chèques sont à
remettre directement auprès des
structures d'accueil pour plus de
renseignements sur le dispositif
vous pouvez appeler le 02 62 90 07 48
vous adresser à la pmi la plus proche de
chez vous ou vous rendre sur le site du
département au www.cegedim.fr
m